hi I'm Jennifer Evans cariño president
of sugar Swan marketing author of
Pinterest marketing an hour a day in the
social media faculty chair at market
motive thanks for joining me for part
one in my series on Pinterest marketing
if you're not familiar with Pinterest
and sort of what it is and how it works
it's fairly easy to get the basic
concept down pat it's basically a
web-based version of an inspiration
board where you can collect ideas and
references and pictures and information
for things that you're interested in
things you might be researching or
things you might be preparing for so if
you remember maybe your grandmother your
mother might have had manila envelope
that sat in the junk drawer in her
kitchen that had clipped out recipes or
clipped out ideas for how she might want
to decorate the house or make a change
of some place this basically takes that
same concept of how we've always been
tied to gathering information together
and it puts it into a socialized
web-based environment where that sort of
collection activity can be shared with
other people that have similar interests
and ideas it's a place to take those
pieces of content those ideas that you
spot online that's a that's a really
cool idea I'd really like to do that and
to categorize it and save it in a visual
environment some place that we're
probably more likely to go back and
connect with it
if you think about how bookmarking has
traditionally worked in the world of the
web it's text-based you know if you use
the bookmarks or the favorites that are
built into your browser you tend to end
up with big long lists and folders of
just all sorts of text links that we
really don't go back and end up using
that much later down the line because a
lot of times we don't take the time to
customize those descriptions and becomes
kind of difficult to remember why we
might have even put them in there in the
first place now with Pinterest on the
other hand because everything has a
visual context to it there's a much
higher level of recall it's much easier
to say you know not just I'm looking for
that corn fritter recipe but here's the
specific corn fritter recipe I'm looking
at because I remember that image behind
it or when you're looking for
inspiration of what you might want to
have as an outdoor project this year
maybe you're looking for that
infographic that had that data you
needed for your presentation it's much
easier to go back in and find it
visually than it is to go through again
the traditional text-based bookmarks
that most of us are used to working with
it's also a place to go for inspiration
and to gather new ideas not just to save
the ideas that you found other places on
the web but to browse through specific
topics and to spot those little pieces
of information that you say hey this has
value to me I want to save that and
categorize that as well finding
inspiration on those topics that you
enjoy and that you're interested in
to that extent it's made a lot of
changes in the way that we do idea
searching online and in fact we've even
started to see a little bit of changes
in the way Google and Bing start to
present some of their information
because of the influence that we see
Pinterest having on how people search so
if you think about going to Google or
going to Bing and running a search say
for blackberry cobbler the results that
you get back may have a couple ads here
and there they may have some images but
for the most part they're going to be
text-based descriptions that have maybe
the added credibility of a website you
recognize but you don't really know what
you're going to get on the other end
until you click that link go through to
the site and actually look on it now
when you run that same search on
pinterest you're instantly getting a
visual representation of the content and
if you're looking for a specific type of
blackberry cobbler becomes a lot easier
to take a look and say oh wow that one
sounds wonderful but you're also reading
curated descriptions that are added by
human beings rather than the metadata or
the relevant content off the page that's
pulled by a search engine algorithm and
plugged into that space nope interest
also makes it very easy for you to
refine your search as you can see across
the top maybe you want an easy
blackberry cobbler recipe or maybe you
want a blackberry cobbler recipe with
oats they can take the user data and the
way the information is saved and
collected within Pinterest and help you
refine those searches further so it also
has a heavy impact again on the way that
people are now doing discovery for
different ideas and concepts
so it's important to be able to look at
Pinterest in sort of the broader context
of what we're used to with social media
so if for example Pinterest is one of
the newer channels to you but maybe
you're familiar with Facebook because
Facebook is sort of the behemoth of all
things social media having a little bit
of side-by-side comparison can be a
helpful way to put Pinterest into
perspective so when we look at monthly
usage data for the two sites the average
person spends about seven hours a month
on Facebook and about 90 minutes a month
on Pinterest no at surface that would
seem like people are way more invested
in facebook than they are in Pinterest
and to an extent that's true again it
has a higher usage rate it has more
frequent visit rate but it's also
important to understand the context of
how we use these two sites because
facebook is a place that is a
destination rather than a starting point
we go to Facebook to participate in
conversations to see what people are
interested in and talking about and to a
great extent to have that conversation
and engagement on facebook itself
Pinterest on the other hand is sort of a
strange hybrid of say a search engine
and a social media site because it's a
starting point it's the place that we go
to either build our collection to look
at other people's collections or for
inspiration so we're spending as much
time off site as we are on site again
the same way that you might go to Google
20 times a day but not spend more than
10 or 15 minutes total during the day on
the site because you're using the site
to get yourself to another location so
we're Facebook becomes that place where
you're engaging with your fans Pinterest
is the place where you're attracting
your fans researching them and what
their likes and what their interests are
so again Facebook is a place where we're
going and we're trying to get people to
stay and engage and interact with us and
sort of spread things around but with
Pinterest there's sort of an
understanding that you're getting a
touch point in front of them and you're
getting an interest point in front of
them but ideally they're finding their
way into your site into your content
again it's a launch point rather than
the actual
engagement location
there's still a lot of misconceptions
about the site who uses it how they use
it whether or not it's a good fit for a
particular business or brand so I want
to clear up some of the misconceptions
that a lot of marketers and a lot of
business owners still have a lot of
people still look at Pinterest is sort
of the way it originally launched which
was mostly about women either planning
their wedding or ones who wish they were
still planning their wedding because
suddenly they had all these great ideas
a little bit of designers and foodies
mixed in then maybe some men you know
hiding in the very very corners and
edges of the Pinterest universe but for
the most part pinterest was originally
all fashion makeup beauty food and home
design now we've seen a lot of changes
in the demographics over the last couple
of years in fact there really is sort of
a new reality and we're seeing a
continued creep towards this new reality
so currently nearly a third of Pinterest
users are actually men 71 percent or
women twenty-nine percent are men that
accounts for about thirteen percent of
the mail internet population now having
a Pinterest account where is forty-two
percent of female Internet users have an
account now when we look a little bit
beyond sort of just the male female
demographic the financial numbers
they're pretty good sixty-four percent
nearly two-thirds of them make more than
50,000 a year and a pretty good
percentage of them also make more than a
hundred thousand dollars a year now one
of the areas that Pinterest does differ
from some of the other channels like
Twitter is that it's a very non urban
environment so if we look at a channel
like Twitter we see a very high urban
population much higher adoption rates
there but with Pinterest we see a lot
more suburban and even way more rural
than we see on some of the other
channels again it's just a different
demographic that's checking in here so
it becomes a unique place to go and
reach some of the people that you might
have a more difficult time reaching on
some of the other platforms and channels
2014 was really a banner year for men on
pinterest and we really by the end of
that year saw a lot of very significant
changes they accounted for thirty-three
percent of all the new signups coming in
and if you go outside of the United
States that's roughly fifty percent of
the signups that are happening so we saw
seventy-three percent year-over-year
growth in men registering for the site I
think women will probably always be the
dominant demographic that's on the site
but I think we're going to continue to
see the number of men increase a little
bit more until we sort of reach a
leveling off now an important thing to
note again when you think about how
you're getting in front of your audience
and whether or not it's a worthwhile
place to check out it's very important
to realize more men now read Pinterest
each month then Sports Illustrated and
GQ combined so again we're getting
really good depth of insight now when we
look at emerging markets Korea India
China the numbers are even better men
make up half of all users not half of
sign ups you know not half of growth
it's literally a 50-50 split when we
look at some of those emerging markets
so if you're doing a lot of
international marketing or if you're
primarily focused and international
marketing it becomes even more important
to look at Pinterest in how you might
work it into your outreach efforts now
some of the top categories for men
because most people are very familiar
with which ones perform best for women
food home design for you know gardening
fashion all of those perform really well
for women when we look at the categories
for men geek tends to be the number one
category so anything you have technology
geeky oriented does really well cars and
motorcycles men's fashion does extremely
well gardening performs very well for
men architecture humor and health and
fitness tend to really be the places
where there's the most activity going on
but in this day and age you can also go
into foodie you can go into outdoors
travel you can go into a variety of
different boards and you're still going
to see a lot of active pinning and
engagement and interaction by men
now with all of this discovery and with
growing demographics coming into the
site it also means that Pinterest has
some pretty impressive traffic potential
looking at some of the stats that have
come out pakora has done a great job of
sort of tracking to see how do people
engage with Pinterest you know what's
going on with a site we find that the
average pin drives two visits and six
page views it's also worth an average of
about seventy eight cents and sales now
when we look at this in terms of sort of
morality we see that the average pin
also receives 11 reap ends now if you're
a big Twitter user you're familiar with
the idea of retweets so to give you a
little perspective on that that makes
the average pin roughly a hundred times
more viral than the average tweet which
receives what about point one percent
repin 0.01 percent reap ends so again
when we look at the potential for things
to spread and move around at a faster
pace pinterest has a lot of potential
but one of the other interesting things
about Pinterest is the latent nature of
traffic and purchases that come in from
it it's not uncommon for a pin to go up
have a really big traffic spike then it
sort of dies off and then someone else
discovers it you know because they're
running a search or they're looking
somewhere they pin it it gets back into
the feed nice and fresh traffic spikes
again or people pin content without
having visited the site to read it and
then they go back and review it later so
roughly half of all visits that come in
from pinterest occur three months after
the original pin was released or the
original pin was made and about half of
all orders occur two months after which
again if people are researching
christmas lists maybe putting together
you know potential purchase lists for
things they're going to buy for their
house or for themselves it makes sense
that they would do their research do
their gathering and then go back at a
later point to kind of dig in a little
bit more and make that final purchase
decision
now Pinterest also has some true
ecommerce potential it's not just about
driving traffic we've also found that
Pinterest is very effective at getting
those actual conversions so looking at
some of the Pinterest shopping stats
forty-seven percent of online shoppers
have made a purchase based on a
Pinterest recommendation and when we
look at ecommerce social sharing though
not social sharing in general but
sharing of products things you intend to
buy Pinterest holds forty-one percent of
e-commerce social sharing now Facebook
sits at 37 to give you a little bit of
perspective so again far more ecommerce
social sharing taking place on the
Pinterest platform and then when we look
at purchases coming in you know I
mentioned 78 cents per pin is sort of
the average but when people actually do
come in and convert and by we see an
average purchase amount of 179 dollars
coming off of a Pinterest referral we
compare that to Facebook we get eighty
dollars at Facebook and sixty nine
dollars at Twitter so if we want to do
the math to put this in a little more
perspective that means that Pinterest
generates on average twenty-seven
percent more revenue per click then
Facebook does and that it generates
roughly four hundred percent more
revenue per click than Twitter now this
makes a lot of sense if you think about
it because when people are on Twitter
they're usually checking to see what's
the news what's sort of the trending
topics what are people talking about but
not necessarily in a shopping mindset
when they're on Facebook they're
catching up with friends and with the
new sources that they follow and kind of
seeing you know just what's the word
what's happening online but when people
are on pinterest there in that sort of
you know small child going to mcdonalds
to get the latest happy meal toy you
know collect them all mode there in that
mindset already of gathering and
acquiring and collecting and a lot of
times they're using it specifically as
part of their purchasing decisions so
they're already in a mental state or
mental mindset when they come into your
website to be prepared for purchase
they're also going to be more apt to use
something like Pinterest or research
higher ticket items so whether that's
you know your wedding dress instead of
maybe the you know the little favors
that you're going to buy for Michaels or
maybe it's you know
a leather couch that you're going to put
in your living room instead of the
pillow that you're going to pick up a
target it's a higher-end product that
they're saving and then collecting so
again you're going to have a higher
dollar amount when they actually do come
through and make that purchase
now I also want to touch on the idea of
Pinterest and how it has changed the
value of images because everyone knows
image marketing over the last several
years it's become really hot there's a
lot of focus on it and Pinterest has
really played a big role in the
development of that now if we think back
several years ago to the earlier days of
social media to youtube and how YouTube
changed video marketing what happened
with YouTube is that we had this
explosion of consumer generated content
and that content was very well received
in fact when we looked at data in way
back in 2012 we could see that
user-generated content and
professionally produced content that was
paired with user-generated content
performed far better across the board
then professionally produced only
content in other words when it looked
like it came from a quote real person
rather than an advertising agency people
tend to relate to it better share it
more and have a more positive response
the trust factor is higher and that
became a really great thing for
businesses of all size because you
didn't necessarily have to pour as much
you know money and planning and skill
set into every video you produced
there's still a place for professionally
produced video but it also meant it was
a little more acceptable to not be at
that rate so for small businesses in
particular this was like a godsend in
the marketing world no unfortunately
we've sort of seen the exact opposite
thing happen with Pinterest because with
Pinterest we see the quality of images
going up exponentially and thus we see a
need for that quality of images and
again when you think about the visual
context why we go to Pinterest what
we're looking for this makes sense very
quickly if you're going to pinterest
because you're looking for a little
dinner inspiration what are you gonna
make for dinner and you run across the
picture like this you're not really
going to be in a hurry to run home and
make that because what is it and why
would I want to eat it but when you pair
it the same recipe with a good quality
image that lets you see oh well you know
that's an egg tart or it's a frittata
okay well that actually that looks a
little better that
it's tastier and this is what we're
seeing happen with Pinterest as we're
seeing all of these bloggers and all of
these websites that are producing
amazing content an amazing video you
take a site like smitten kitchen she's
operating out of a 42 square foot
kitchen in New York City she doesn't
have staff there's no production studio
there she's not a trained chef but she
puts up the recipes that she makes and
she pairs it with gorgeous photos that
she takes herself and she's pulling in
millions of page views every single week
and probably a nice chunk in advertising
revenue as well but the same way that we
saw sort of amateurs dramatically
changed the nature of video marketing by
using more amateurish content again
we've seen the exact opposite happen
with images because in an environment
that you need things to be so visually
stimulating to stand out on that
Pinterest page the best quality content
is what's going to reign supreme and as
you have people who are willing to put
the time and effort in and who are
creating better content that's upping
the bar for everyone else so what it has
meant for a lot of brands big and small
is that relying so heavily on stock
photography like they used to in the
past doesn't work so well anymore not
when you're competing with really unique
original relevant images that people are
taking of what they're producing you
know they're putting up not just a blog
post but a blog post that has 20 amazing
images to go with it and so we've seen
this sort of across the board level of
expectation that no matter what size
company you are you need to learn how to
properly operate a camera how to put
some good lighting in there and to
really great get some great imagery
again enterprise or small business it's
irrelevant at this point the quality of
your pictures must go up on your website
if you want to reap the benefits and the
rewards that come from the increased
traffic from the service like Pinterest
so before we get into the next couple
sets of videos for this series I really
want to sort of go back and kind of
summarize this idea of why pinterest is
worth looking at if you're not already
marketing in it or why you might want to
put some consideration into some of the
different ways you might be able to
leverage it really at its core Pinterest
is probably the strongest site online in
the social media world playing off the
impact of imagery photos way incredibly
heavily they are the currency of
Pinterest but that allows for really
fast concept digestion so unlike on
Twitter or unlike on a Facebook where
there's a lot of reading as you're
scrolling through to figure out is this
something I'm interested in we can react
to and process images very quickly so
having the opportunity to get your
content into that environment gives you
a much better chance to really capture
someone's eyes and get them to stop and
take the time to read the description
and potentially click through to the
site there's also a really low barrier
to entry it rivals Twitter in terms of
how quickly you can get in there and set
things up for a base level Pinterest
account you know even getting your
website verified you're looking at five
to ten minutes to set up now if you're
going to go a little heavier duty with
things like rich pins which we'll talk
about a little later in this series
there's going to be a little bit more
effort there but it basically has a
really simple interface with minimal
management there's not a lot to it that
is going to take up a ton of time and
effort management wise there's also the
ability to look at this as a chance for
curation vs creation we're going to talk
a little more in depth about that idea
later in the series as well but it
basically gives you the opportunity to
have a channel that you can play in
without necessarily having to create all
original content there are some very
successful in strategic ways to leverage
Pinterest with other people's content
rather than your own and then finally
the ability to have content segmentation
which is another idea that will dig a
little deeper into gives you the chance
to really target your consumers in a way
that you can't do on any other social
media channel because the idea that
people can choose which areas of your
content they want to follow that allows
you to curate much deeper
into a topic then you would normally be
able to
now there's tons of potential here for
big brands we see big companies
enterprise-level businesses really
leveraging it very creatively one of the
examples that I've used almost from the
start with Pinterest is chobani because
they have non-stop done an amazing job
of marketing and one of the things that
you know they've said is it has really
allowed them to show different sides of
their personality again that idea of the
content segmentation and being able to
dig a little deeper it really lets
people see more about what the brand of
chobani is and all the different ways
that people are using their products so
whether Chobani's leveraging it to find
recipes that they might want to send to
their Test Kitchen to see about
leveraging on their own blogs research
to see how customers are using their
product and from their end while they're
gathering a lot of insight and data
again there's minimal engagement and
management going on they're not usually
in their comment saying they don't have
to read through a lot of comments and
respond to them they're mostly just
curating and liking and repenting
content now for small brands we see the
same things there's been a lot of
companies that have done a really great
job of leveraging Pinterest to get
exposure and artifact uprising is a
great example of this one of those
companies that was a small teeny tiny
startup literally working out of
someone's basement and they had a single
product pin that generated almost 50,000
visitors into their site and in 18
months they went from basement startup
to multi-million dollar sales just
because they got the right pin in front
of the right person and got some really
great exposure so they've been using it
to do a lot of a be testing of products
that they're looking to launch before
they actually get them lunch just to see
what the responses and what people seem
to be interested in and that's really
given them as a small company the
ability to gather a lot of really unique
and creative data that otherwise might
have cost them a lot of money to hire a
market research for him to put together
so there's lots of different ways the
companies of all sizes are really
working to leverage Pinterest
so coming up in the next part of our
series we're going to talk a little bit
about setting up a Pinterest account you
know personal accounts versus business
accounts we'll look at the various types
of pin boards understanding what they
are and how to use them and we're going
to talk a little more in depth about
this idea of content segmentation and
the value associated with that thank you
so much for joining me for part one and
our series on pinterest marketing